Amazon is named after the largest river in
the world - you can see it in the business'
early logo. The river may flow through
the tropical forests of South America
but it seems the company has an even bigger reach.
Amazon went from selling books in 1995 to selling
everything. Jeff Bezos believes its success
can be boiled down to a philosophy he described
in an interview with CNBC during the early days.
If there's one thingAamazon.com is about it's
obsessive attention to the customer experience
end to end. A big part of focusing on the customer
experience is in the area of delivery. Packages
often arrive well before they're supposed to
even if you don't have Prime. And if you do,
deliveries are getting faster: going from two
days to one, to same-day shipping. But that
all pales in comparison to what comes next.
This giant floating airship is deploying packages
carried by Amazon drones except it isn't real.
Here's the original rendering. The Japanese
filmmaker who made this told me he posted it as
a joke. It just so happens that a few years ago,
Amazon did file a patent for a floating warehouse.
Imagine a fulfillment center stocked with products
in the air flying to places where demand is high
like sporting events. When the airship needs to
restock, a smaller one will meet it in the skies,
bringing along staff, drones, fuel, and
inventory. Companies file patents all the
time but it doesn't necessarily translate
into anything real. What this does show
is Amazon's ambitions for its drones and it
started out with deliveries here in the UK.
Two hours north of London, in the Cambridge
area, Richard Barnes became the first customer
to receive an order by drone as part of Amazon's
test trial. After putting in his purchase,
a fulfillment center received it, then packaged
up the items. The maximum weight the drone can
carry is five pounds which doesn't sound like
a lot, although Amazon points out 75 to 90
percent of its orders are under that limit.
The drone makes its way down an automated
track before rising like a helicopter to nearly
400 feet. It's guided by GPS to the destination
and uses sense and avoid technology to detect the
surroundings. Amazon promises Prime Air will make
deliveries in 30 minutes or less. Since that
trial in 2016, the drone's design has changed.
The latest version has a noticeable tilt allowing
use of all six propellers to move forward. Tests
are still being carried out in the UK and around
the world and they could be coming to America.
Earlier this year, Amazon received U.S.
federal approval to operate as a drone company,
joining two others: Wing Aviation, owned
by Google's parent company Alphabet,
and UPS Flight Forward. Getting the okay from
the FAA wasn't easy. Amazon had to prove its
operations were safe. The drones are jam-packed
with three types of sensors: visual, thermal,
and sonar. No sensor by itself can do it all
and let me give you an example: fluffy dogs
are invisible to sonar. Besides looking out for
cute fluffy pets, the sensors can detect when a
person gets too close and very significantly can
spot things as thin as clotheslines in a backyard
or wires. Still, when we're talking about an
unmanned aerial vehicle, it's not without risks.
In case of a catastrophic failure, another patent
shows the drone breaking apart deliberately in
midair, splitting on the ground and in a lake,
before a controlled collision into a tree.
The reasoning is if it's going to crash, better
it be in small chunks rather than a big one.
Another option is to rely on parachutes for
the landing. The California startup Zipline
uses that method to deliver life-saving
blood supplies to rural areas in Rwanda.
While continuing to develop the technology
to make it as safe as possible, Amazon has
to figure out the logistics of making drone
deliveries within the tight 30-minute window.
Fulfillment centers are usually located on the
outskirts of cities to accommodate their large
size yet this is inconvenient for deliveries into
cities where a growing number of people live.
One solution is constructing a different kind
of fulfillment center that can be tucked into
downtown, blending into the surroundings - such
as this cylindrical building or a beehive-like
structure that resembles London's iconic Gherkin
skyscraper. This can also act as a command center
similar to a flight controller at an airport
managing traffic as drones come and go. These
flying machines can travel up to 15 miles before
running out of power. Instead of heading back to
the fulfillment center to replenish the batteries,
they can do so on a structure like a lamppost
which would be reconfigured to allow for charging
and also double as a pickup and drop-off point for
packages. The drones would communicate with a
central control system either through a wired
or wireless connection, bringing free wi-fi to the
area. Amazon thinks this kind of setup can extend
to pretty much any tall structure such as parking
decks, church steeples, and cell towers. So there
are many options to consider and a combination
of any or all of them could very well be used.
Although many regulatory hurdles still have to be
cleared, if and when drones take off on a large
scale, they will change our idea of delivery. We
will no longer think in terms of days or hours but
minutes. I mentioned the company's guiding
philosophy is the focus on customer experience
but there is another philosophy at Amazon's
headquarters in Seattle. Bezos named one of
the buildings Day One, treating every day like
the first day of a startup, in order to work
quickly and focus on results. If it's day one
at Amazon, then they're just getting started.
Thanks so much for watching, I'm Cindy
Pom. So what do you think of Amazon's
drone delivery service? Do you think the best
option is airships a beehive like structure
downtown? Let me know your thoughts. If
you like what you saw, give it a like,
and don't forget to subscribe to my channel. Thank
you as always to my Patrons for your continued
support. A shout out goes out to my Patreon
Producer Nino Gjoni. I will see you very soon